the European Union is planning to bring
more sanctions against Russia over its
so-called referendums in occupied parts
of Ukraine more Russian Goods could be
banned and Technology exports stopped if
EU States agree on the steps Moscow
claims up to 99 percent of residents in
parts of Ukraine voted yes to annexation
now many residents are packing their
bags and leaving before Russia can claim
possession of the region
these people are fleeing
russian-occupied eastern Ukraine about a
thousand people arrive at this
checkpoint in super regia every day the
number of those leaving has only
increased since the so-called
referendums calling for a formal
annexation by Russia began last week
they describe a procedure that is
anything but democratic
we ran into soldiers they asked if we
had voted we said yes they said let's do
it again
some say they were forced to vote at
gunpoint and soldiers checked their
ballots
speaking about the referendums Ukrainian
President Vladimir solenski thanked
Western leaders for condemning the
fabricated vote
thank you all for your clear and
unequivocal support thank you all for
understanding our position Ukraine
cannot and will not put up with any
attempts by Russia to seize any part of
our land
in the U.S zelenski's predictions were
echoed by the White House
these referenda are illegitimate and
frankly outrageous we expect Russia to
use these sham referenda as a false
pretext to try to Annex Ukrainian
territory in flagrant violation of
international law and the United Nations
Charter in fact Russia's actions are
transparently fraudulent and have no
legal significance whatsoever
we will never recognize these illegal
and illegitimate attempts at annexation
the Sham referendums prompted the EU to
call for a new sanctions package against
Russia it would be the eighth package so
far and include tighter trade
restrictions among them a price cap for
Russian oil
thank you madam president
the Sham referenda organized in the
territories that Russia occupied
are an illegal attempt to grab land and
to change International borders by force
the mobilization and put in threat to
use nuclear weapons are further steps on
the escalation path
Russian installed leaders in the
occupied regions of Donetsk luhansk
saparee John Harrison have already
formally asked the Russian president to
incorporate their territories into
Russia
a correspondent Matthias Berlinger joins
us from the Ukrainian Capital cave the
U.S will deliver 18 additional hymas to
Ukraine what will the rocket systems do
to Ukraine's fighting capacity
the hymers have been very effective
in this war on the Ukrainian side
Ukraine has been able to hit uh deep
behind the Russian lines and to hit
supply lines there which has
considerably uh made it more difficult
for Russia to bring ammunition for
example to the front lines Etc big
ammunition dumps have been hit by these
high mass Bridges Etc however of course
due in the course of a war every new
weapon system is most effective when
it's new and later the other side adapts
to it so these spectacular explosions of
ammunition Depots that we've seen in the
beginning it's not it's not very
probable that we will see them again
Russia has adapted and they have
distributed
um their supplies uh in a way that
they're less easy to eat however it's a
powerful and very precise weapon and it
has turned the tide in Ukraine's favor
when it was first used and the
likelihood of Ukraine positioning those
missiles to put it within range of
Crimea
so there's different types of missiles
that can be used with these with these
sets the ones that Ukraine has been
delivered officially so far they reach
about 80 kilometers that's there's no
way that Ukraine can reach Crimea with
these uh however we've seen strikes on
Crimea we've seen strikes on the sake
Airfield and uh there has been a lot of
speculation whether those attackers
these missiles that can reach 300
kilometers wide whether they have
already arrived in Ukraine although both
sides the US and Ukraine are denying
that they are in possession of them but
it remains a mystery how Ukraine was
able to strike this Airfield and
speculation uh is is about that there
might be already some supplies of these
attackers these attackers of course
would also put the bridge that connects
Crimea to Russia within range although
it would probably be difficult to hit it
but within range of the Ukrainian
artillery and of course hitting that
bridge is a major goal of the ukrainians
something they want to do in order to
supply
Russian to to disrupt Russian supply
lines in a more effective way Matthias
Ukrainian forces have been pushing to
encircle another city in the East what
are you hearing
so yeah we're talking about Le Mans
liman is one of the cities that Russia
was able to capture when they when they
started or when they pushed their
offensive in the donbass through and now
Ukrainian troops have been advancing
mostly from the east from the kharkiv
region but also from the south and it
looks a little bit like they would be
able to close the ring and besiege the
city this would be the first Siege to to
a major
settlement controlled by the Russians
and would be the second Siege in this
war after Mary yupo and it would of
course be an important game for the
ukrainians if they can take this city it
would be the first major city major
settlement to be taken back by the
ukrainians in the donbass region that
region that Russia has declared the main
objective of its offensive
a teaspoon guy in Ukraine Forest
covering events there thank you very
much